豊臣秀行 天下一のぶっ飛びマシーン 千葉県出身
織田慎太郎 セオリー無視の一発屋 千葉県出身
徳川康兵衛 麻雀理論を全く持たない タコなき男 千葉県出身
明智光一 超合理的理論麻雀を打つ 試合校舎 千葉県出身
はやみあきな 1号トヨタミの恋人
驚異的な月の持ち主 千葉県出身
ロン めんたんぴん3食 おやまん
キカー
ローン めんちんピンフ ドライチ バイマン
ズガー トレ
ローン 百万
ズギャー ポン
泣いて飛び出る トリプルローン
ズギャー
さあ20箱目乗るかな
俺は乗る方に今日の飯代かけるだ
じゃあ俺は崩れる方
乗った乗った
はい飯おごれよ
何にすっかな
くそ外れた
ああ ということで俺は23万6000点の価値ね
俺は17万8000点
ほらぴったし20万だ
似ておる あの若者 わしの若い頃にそっくりじゃ
こいつだ わしの向かふんだ方を伝授するのはこいつしかおらん
じゃあまたな
元気出すや 豊臣
出すだよ
じゅんちゃん 3食 いいペコ おやっぱね
8,000点 菓子ですね
むかむか
小沢さん どうも調子が良くないようですね
そうですね!この程度だったら、私だってできますよ!
ムカムカムカムカムカムカムカムカムカ!
どーん!
メンホン三眼光、乱発ドライチ、ファイマン!
ムカムカムカ!
おーっと、また振り込んでしまいました!
なーに!小沢様、こんなもんでしょ?
ふーん
こ、これは一体
さーて、とうとうお迎えが来たのかもしれませんね
あはははは
ふん
本朗本一トイントイトンハツドラさんと言っております
驚きました
今まであれほどつかんかった小沢さんが
見事な連続技で論法をいたしました
あれが泣きのポンポコリンという難易度Cのウルトラ技ですね
これは相手に与えるダメージは大きいですよ
こ、これはすごい!一体小沢さんに何が起こったのでありましょうか!
ま、まさか、あれは…
小沢さん、五度目の最強位防衛、おめでとうございます!
オーラスでの反撃はさまじいものがありましたが
あの時一体あなたに何が起こったのですか
ムカフーンじゃよ
ムカフンダホーを使ったのじゃよ
ムカフンダホー
あれが幻のムカフンダホー
な、なんなんですかそのムカフンというのは
そうですね
麻雀をやっていて必要以上に使うときは誰だって
ムカーッときますよね
はい
振り込みが続くとそのムカがやがてムカムカさらにムカムカムカとなっていきます
でもその状態もある一戦を越えると
相手の手に対し素直な反応を示すようになるんです
でこの不運状態になった時打ち手の心が湧き出ずる岩清水のように透明な境地に達し
信じられないような月が回ってきます
これがその変化を表したグラフです
これこそ泣く子も振り込む究極の極意
一死争伝の幻の必殺技と言えましょう
無我不運打法 恐るべし
俺をこんな山奥まで連れてきてどうするつもりだ
黙ってわしの言うことを聞け
お主麻雀に強くなりたくないのか
え?
勝って勝って勝ちまくり日本最強のジャンシーとして
あがめられたくはないのか
お、おめえは一体何者なんだ
わしか、そのうち分かる時が来ようって
あ、書いてある
あの方が、あの有名な大沢武書房
勝てるかもしれない
あの方について行けば勝てるかもしれない
いつも
お見逃れしました
百天坊ごときでわしを薄取ろうなどと千年早いわ
万天坊で出直してこい
ロン ピンフンのみ
叶ったわけ 誰があれと言った
振り込むのじゃ! 振り込んで! 振り込んで! 振り込みまくるのじゃと言うとろうか!
は、はい
ロン、スーアンコー
ロン、確信無双
無か!
そうじゃ、怒れ! 怒るのじゃ!
ロン、大通信
ムカムカムカムカ
もっと怒れ
怒りが大きければ大きいほど
食うエネルギーの威力はさらに増大する
怒りを体に充満させ
爆発させるのじゃ
麻雀は爆発じゃ
中連ポート
ムカムカムカムカムカムカ
それトラじゃ
お主はトラになるのじゃ
ラブーロン
ついに
後継者が
し、師匠
見事じゃ豊臣
ついにお主は無花粉打法を得得した
まさに童貌な虎と化したのじゃ
師匠
今からお主は日本最強のジャンシーとなろう
日本中のジャンシーたちが
お主の前にひれ伏す時が来たのじゃ
ガクッ
師匠!
せめて知る前に金田屋の羊羹が食いたかったわ
ガクッ
中川本舗のくるみまんじゅうが
いっかげんにしろ!
こんなところにやっと見つけたわ 豊臣くん
豊臣くん
ど、豊臣くん、待って
豊臣くん、何があったの?あのお墓は誰なの?豊臣くん、教えて
俺は虎だ、虎になったんだ
え、それってどういうこと?
小沢竹書房とのつらく厳しい修行に耐え
ついに幻の無花粉打法を得得した豊臣
もはや豊臣の前に敵は存在しないのだ
立て立て立ち上がれ豊臣
勝利に向けて完全と突き進むのだ
トヨトミくん
あの山で一体何があったの
どうして何も言ってくれないの
その
私には言えないことなの
秋野ちゃん
もういいの
あなたはもう
私の知っている豊臣くんじゃなくなってしまったのよ
こんばんはニュースターミナルの時間です
まず今日の最初のニュースをお宮から
日本麻雀会最強と歌われた小沢武書房さん年齢不詳が
1週間ほど前にすでに死亡していたらしいことが
今朝明らかになりました
無敵と言われた無花粉打法はこうして謎に包まれたまま
そのたった一人の使い手を失ってしまったことになります
しかし私も知らなかったんですが
幻の無花粉打法の使い手ってまだこの世にいたんですね
ワタさん
そうですね全く残念ですね
私も若い頃祖父からよく噂を聞かされたもんですけれどもね
とにかく麻雀会は惜しい人物をなくしましたね
我々は元気を出さなきゃいけませんねここはね本当にね本当
慎んでご冥福をお祈りいたします
では次のニュースをお見えから
今日昼頃世田谷区明大前のジャンソーミスチョイスで
何者かが店内の客約20名を麻雀で手玉に取って
箱の山に埋もれさせそれぞれ全地1週間から
1ヶ月の心の傷を負わせた模様です
事態を重く見た当局は付近一帯に限界体制を敷き
犯人の行方を追っています
現場から墓林がレポートします
はい ここは事件があったという 明大前のジャンソーの通りです
日本にもまだこういう場所が 残されているんですね
事件の犯人の手がかりは その後どうですか
はい 今のところ決定的…
あ 向こうで何かが起こったようです
墓林さん 墓林さん
はい 墓林です
たった今ここで事件があった模様です
ではインタビューをしてみましょう
一体ここで何があったんですか
ムカフーンにやられた
梅さん聞こえましたか
ムカフーンムカフーンが現れました
ヒントカンター
小沢竹書房は死んじまったはずだぜ
石竹今ムカフーンにやられたって言ってたぞ
とすればあれ一体誰の仕業だ
やあご無沙汰
トヨトミ
おめえどこ行ってただよ1ヶ月も
心配かけちゃって
俺たちおめえとマージャンやるのだけを楽しみに生きてんだからな
警視庁に捜索願いまで出したの
おめえってやつら
おいおいおい
インインイン
ローン 太陽三色 ゴンニー
ツカー
ム
ムカ
ラン!チュン!トイトイゴッパ!
ムッカムッカー!ムカ!
オン!タンピンイペーコードラドラ!マンガン!
ムカムカムカムカムカムカムカ!
おめえ何イラついてんだ?
楽しくやろうぜ兄弟
久しぶりの麻雀だっぺよ
くそ!
ローン、一万二千!
ムカムカムカムカムカ!
ローン、二万四千!
ムカムカムカムカムカムカムカムカ!
あ、あんた、アニが怒ったか?
と、豊臣、おめえひょっとして、無花粉が使えるのか?
ハネマン!
ブーブー
ん
ああ!ダメだ!無花粉たんほうにはかなわねえべ!
お、落ち着くだ!
俺たちは今に、無花粉地獄にハマって、
二度と麻雀ができない体になっちまうんだ!
ま、まさか、このトヨトミが例のジャンソー嵐だったとは!
はっ!アニッタルだ!それくらいオラでもできた!
んんんんんっ
そっかー出るかー
ピンク
あれまーちんいつもついてりゃ
これはまいったねーどうも
やーおらー
弾来たー
やめろこっちが熱くなったら
ムカ踏んのおのうちつぼだ
いつものペースでやるしかないんだ
うっせームカ踏んだか何踏んだか
知らねーがほらムカ飲みだほうで
十分だよ
くそー、俺もだんだん頭に来たぞー
おりゃー、一発相撲、ウェアマン
むかむかむかむか、この野郎、俺一人だけ上がらせねえか
おら!相撲!
おやっぱね!
ロンだ!ロンだ!それ当たりだ!ベロー!
おら!ドタカメ相撲だ!さっさと展望払いやがれ!
ざまぁ!ミソラシュドウ!
大万だ!早くよこせ!
100万だ!これちくしょう!
バカめ!おやばいな!クソッタレ!
何だ、クソッタレイ!
何だ、つってんだろうが!
やる気あんのか、ヘタクソが!
そうはいかねえ!
で、結局新しくなったあなたは
マージャンに勝ったの?
明菜ちゃん、俺は勝ち負けなんざどうでもいいのさ。
自分の納得できる麻雀が打てれば、それで十分なんだ。
つまり、負けたのね。
明菜ちゃん!
豊臣くん!
僕ね、僕ね!
いいのよ。何も言わなくても。
これでこそいつもの豊臣くんよ
こうして一死争殿 泣く子も振り込む幻の必殺技 無花粉打法は
その姿を伝説という名のもと 歴史の中へ埋もらせてしまおうとしていた
ええええええ
ごはんしもうたもしかするとわしのせっかくの無花粉た方法を伝える人間を完璧に 間違ってしまったかも
を走れんかもしれんぞよ
ガクッ
うわっ、小沢一生の不覚であ…
こ、このままではわし…
ガクッ
一生やってろ
彼はもう、かれこれ7年の間、天敗したことがない
最後のあの日のことを彼は今でも思い出す
彼の名はサンタクロース
次回しびれてなんぼ
サンタの街がやってきた
きっと見てね
眠っちゃいや
ミナミハンフォー!
せずなさわぐなあわてるな
パイをつかんねばせんぞくのまんのゆめがわく
うんふうてんふうとりしょうかくる
とべてくるんだといぬんさん
つかんとうかねばならぬのだ
リッチバッティングリッチ
ひもちゃかみちゃばじゃんなかま
しょうぶかけたらなさきおよごのめらいうち
ご視聴ありがとうございました
マーケングーにやりづいて
かつて飲み干すビールがうまい
スカンゾー!
お酒は命がけ!
がけかれた!
だだらららららー!
ご視聴ありがとうございました